wissen sie was richtig blöd ist wenn man
was verliert schlüssel handy nervt total
es ist unglaublich was wir schüssel
alles verlieren
deutschland hat seit beginn der korona
pandemie tausende pflegekräfte verloren
sowohl in krankenhäusern als auch in
alten- und pflegeheim wo hab ich denn
meine pflegekräfte jetzt wieder
hingelegt über 9.000 sind uns von der
fahne gegangen letztes jahr ist das der
dank fürs klatschen auf dem balkon
tatsächlich kann man es natürlich
verstehen der pflege bedarf ist größer
denn je und die arbeitsbedingungen sind
nicht wirklich besser geworden um es
nett auszudrücken
jetzt ist auch noch der sehnsüchtig
erwartete flächendeckenden tarifvertrag
für die altenpflege geplatzt
ja veto von der caritas dabei hatte die
groko doch versprochen den pflegeberuf
ein bisschen mehr zweck zu verleihen
sagt man so oder es nur school werden
pflegekraft zu sein und da machen wir
druck das mag man radikal nennen oder
nicht oder krass radikal krass kolonat
ja gerade im privaten pflegeheim wird
man oft radikal schlecht bezahlt und
muss krass viel arbeiten da kann man die
fluchtbewegung schon sehr gut
nachvollziehen
experten schätzen rund 30.000 fachkräfte
fehlen um sich dem gewünschten
betreuungsschlüssel wenn ich es ein
bisschen anzunähern und diese experten
hier sagt was helfen würde
dies ist personal muss mehr geld tank
damit überhaupt jemanden auf den beruf
überhaupt preis umso toller dass die
beiden es trotzdem machen oder
ja sie hat das liebevoll gemeinte und
die pflegeschüler haben ja auch darüber
gelacht bevor sie dann im park vergessen
haben der weltverband der pflegekräfte
warnt wegen corona vor einem
massenexodus aus ihrem beruf wenig
überraschend in deutschland guckt der
staat zu wie sich private investoren
immer mehr pflegebetten kaufen als
investment was die löhne natürlich
drückt gleichzeitig hat jens spahn
versucht in mexiko pflegekräfte
abzuwerben
mexiko war das denn sinn
wo waren da denn bitte die trompeten
lügen presse 80 prozent der heimbewohner
und pflegekräfte in deutschland sind
inzwischen gegen korona geimpft 80
prozent deutlich schlechter sieht es aus
für die die zu hause versorgt werden
immerhin drei viertel aller
pflegebedürftigen da warten viele noch
auf die erste impfung zu hause pflegen
angehörige oder osteuropäische
fachkräfte die bei uns längst
systemrelevant sind
ohne die geht in der 24 stunden pflege
gar nichts mehr
nix betreuung rund um die uhr wenn sie
sich da eher streng ans deutsche
arbeitsrecht halten dann dann kostet das
zwölf- bis 15.000 euro im monat weil
drei bis vier vollzeitkräfte eingesetzt
werden müssen
die osteuropäische betreuungskräfte
haben sich durchgesetzt weil sie
deutlich günstiger sind je nach
legalität kostete es zwischen 1500 und
3000 euro
ja 15.000 im monat oder 3000 die dritte
variante
und so machen wir das in ostwestfalen
die eltern gehen rechtzeitig in den wald
und den rest regeln die wölfe es geht
auch geht auch deutschland verlässt sich
längst auf seine pflege armee aus
osteuropa falsch geändert pol im mio
können die alten leute nicht ist egal
und es ist auch egal ob legal oder
illegal wir brauchen diese frauen sonst
bricht die pflege in deutschland
zusammen dass es fakt gebt denen endlich
rechtssicherheit also den status der
arbeitnehmer ähnlichen selbstständigen
dann werden sie auch in der
sozialversicherung und alle sind happy
gilt zu sauerbraten a big band görner
sauerbraten mit dem google übersetzer da
geht es am ende meistens fischstäbchen
trotzdem süß laut verdi erwartet nur
jeder fünfte in der altenpflege den job
bis zum rentenalter wirklich machen zu
können und das ist ein realistischer
einschätzung leider man muss es noch mal
sagen das ist wirklich eine der
wichtigsten und zugleich härtesten
arbeiten überhaupt körperlich und
psychisch und trotzdem verdient man
deutlich weniger als ein krankenpfleger
es gibt immer noch keine bundesweit
einheitlichen personalschlüssel so dass
du oft nachts alleine für eine ganze
pflegestation zuständig ist
und am ende ist dein rücken so im eimer
hast du selber zum pflegefall wirst ja
meine welche ironie verdi und die
arbeitgeber einigen sich also endlich
auf einen allgemein gültigen
tarifvertrag für die pflege und dann
scheitert das ausgerechnet an der
caritas die katholische
wohlfahrtsorganisation legt ihr veto ein
und das obwohl der arbeitsminister den
wirklich massiv druck gemacht hat das
müssen die entscheiden aber ich sag mal
politisch ich finde das schon schön so
schön die aber nicht tausende
pflegekräfte die in privaten heimen
deutlich weniger verdienen als sie in
den kirchlichen hatten sich gefreut auf
etwas mehr lohn
und jetzt kommen sie in die röhre bzw
bettpfanne ich begrüße birte schneider
von der caritas frau schneider aktuell
im schnitt nur 11 euro 40 mindestlohn in
der pflege in manchen heimen privaten
heimen mit tricks sogar weniger und
ihretwegen geht das jetzt weiter caritas
ist lateinisch und das heißt so viel wie
das ist ja nun wirklich nicht unser
problem wird zahlen in unseren
einrichtungen gute löhne stichwort
fachkräftemangel gesunder wettbewerb
will sagen im prinzip ist ja super da
anderswo so wenig gezahlt wird denn dann
können wir die guten leute abwerben aha
steht das denn so in der bibel ja ja das
ist aus dem dritten buch rummenigge
brief an die borussen und der herr
sprach gehe hin und kaufte der
konkurrenz die leistungsträger
der herr hoeneß sprach das vielleicht
aber kapieren sie gar nicht wen die
caritas mit ihrem tarif veto hilft den
ausbeutern natürlich werden sich die
privaten pflegeheimbetreiber sehr
gefreut haben dass man ihnen diese
arbeit abgenommen hat wie es jetzt
gelaufen es hat die caritas im prinzip
diese drecksarbeit für die privat
gewerblichen heimbetreiber erledigt er
für andere die drecksarbeit machen genau
das ist doch der christliche gedanke nur
im übrigen nur mal zum nachdenken jesus
hat seinen jüngern die füße gewaschen
aber hat er ihnen einen tarifvertrag zu
jedem nein er muss doch unterschiede
geben
judas zum beispiel hat 30 silberlinge
mehr verdient als die kollegen und haben
die sich beschwert weiß ich gar nicht
natürlich gebe ich ihnen recht ist das
eigentliche problem dass inzwischen 42
prozent der heime privatisiert sind
profit zwang ergo lohndumping
trotzdem hätte es jetzt endlich mal
mindeststandards geben können mehr lohn
bei den arbeitszeiten ihr habt das
verhindert werke den anklagenden tonfall
können sich gerne sparen die caritas ist
ein vorbildlicher arbeitgeber in jeder
hinsicht
niemand hat zb einen besseren
kündigungsschutz als die katholische
kirche ich krieg dazu jeden tag
tonnenweise begeisterte feedback ihr zum
beispiel schreibt ein rainer maria weiss
köln mehr kündigungsschutz geht gar
nicht egal was du hier machst du fliegst
raus von mir fünf sterne fünf sterne und
jetzt kommen sie also die pflegekräfte
in den privaten heim müssen weiter sehen
ich bitte sie
natürlich sind wir auch solidarisch die
armen menschen dort sollen wissen wir
fühlen immer mit euch und hat muss er
noch mal reichen
so und nun liebe enttäuschte gemeinde
singen wir noch gemeinsam sieht 550
[Musik]
private pflege
hallo youtube unten könnt ihr den kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
info box neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante videos verlinkungen komma
vielen dank
[Musik]